you don't want to be around people who  don't understand why they're in a bad  mood  if i'm in a bad mood i try to go  like let me figure this out before i let  it out on people but if you lack  emotional intelligence you're probably  more likely to go like i'm in a bad mood  and the people around me are causing it  or i'm justified in being mean to people  because of my bad mood or making these  decisions that affect other people  negatively or myself  negatively  because of this bad mood because it's  like reality it's sort of like people  who are  you know  suicidal it's like they see it as a  rational choice like you know well  obviously like  life is hopeless and i'm worthless and  it's like no no that's your perception  of reality based on  your transient mood right now